okay more with asia wilson coming up
signing day unlv had it
they're very happy with their signing
day this year a record-breaking signing
day
this past week for the rebels also
signing day for local football players
is happening john treach
does it better than anybody else here's
his story on local players
signing with college teams the pandemic
can steal their senior season
but not their heart not their hope not
their history
what a town what a day i could have gave
up plenty of times with my lifestyle but
i chose to work hard and grind for
something i want
erin joins teammate evan leaving legacy
high school
and leaving a freaking legacy i think
it's a huge step
and it's very exciting for me to be able
to go to play at the next level and
and to be able to continue to do what i
love junior carmona is the big man
on campus at las vegas high and he's
ready to be big time at san jose state
during 2020 it's there's not much that's
exciting
so today is definitely going to be a
great day and i'm going to celebrate it
a lot
jared robinson ran by defenders at
centennial and right
into the rockies you can't get this day
back in and that's really
i want to cherish this with my family
and my friends and everybody
they really mean everything to me dion
washington is a proud las vegas but his
college compass
is taking him north the coaches wanted
me like from the gym they didn't take
any recruiting process they saw my tape
and offered me on the spot
desert pines has become a football
factory they don't get much more
promising than this scholarship
season five the first one in my family
go to college so this is uh this is
pretty big for me a lot of joy to be
able to come to celebrate
me signing and watching my boys sign
it's a lot of joy
it's like a dream come true you know
we've been we've been talking about this
day since we were freshmen
but yeah i'm just proud to be a part of
this program
and then there is iconic liberty forever
connected in the way they chase
challenged and became champions growing
up
you know i started on my church and i
found my talent in football
so that's why i was more emotional
because now you know i have a glimpse of
greatness right now i'm gonna tell my
kids about this and i'm gonna tell my
grandkids about this so
honestly this team and just all my
coaches and all my brothers here at
liberty is just it's amazing
it's just awesome seeing through all the
ups and downs of this year you know kind
of like a roller coaster raining on a
high note
and we're you know we're going to make
something special of all of us las vegas
is best signed scholarships
but they're writing history john treach
8 sports now
thank you john we needed that okay a
feel-good story right here
right now and a story of hope okay
coming up